aujourd'hui on part en voyage j'ai
décidé de vous faire découvrir la suisse
est de vous donner une petite idée de la
richesse de ses paysages et de la
culture helvétique et la surprise c'est
que je ne suis pas seul pour faire ce
voyage je suis avec benjamin friands ben
allez c'est parti
la suisse c'est par là pour commencer
notre voyage je vous propose de
rejoindre ben à montreux à bord d'un
train mythique le golden pass
panoramique
[Musique]
jamais je suis actuellement avec nick la
ceni va nous écrire un petit peu sur
particularité de ce train le mob golden
pass on se retrouve dans le golfe à ce
panoramique
c'est un train spécial avec les grandes
vitres c'était le mb je m'en faire
montre au volant leur demande il ya eu
cette idée de construire des voitures
pareil en 1976 75 ans d'anniversaire de
notre entreprise fonctionne que la
grande découverte à l'époque et c'est
les autres affaires qui ont fait des
répliques après de ce train panoramique
à la vue à l'air vraiment chouette ça
donne envie en tout cas depuis 1905
cette ligne de chemin de fer relie
montreux à zweisimmen le parcours dure
un peu plus de deux heures fait 63 km au
total
et son point culminant se situe près de
chat à 1275 mètres d'altitude le train
offre donc toute une palette de
panoramas en partant des bords du lac
léman jusqu'au paysages alpins de ce
fait simone le parcours permet de
découvrir différents pans de la culture
suisse comme par exemple la fabrication
de nombreux fromages
avant ils vont passer de supporter de
lens qui ont l'argent un instinct jure
linge pour islamique gérer a fait du
fromage
il sent bon la suisse fromage mais il
n'ya pas que du fromage en suisse
il y a aussi des ballons une des
destinations les plus connus sur le
trajet du golden pass c'est bien entendu
château des châteaux des est hyper
connue pour son événement chaque année
de ballons dirigeables ça se passe en
janvier tous les ans et ce musée retrace
l'histoire des ballons de cet événement
et pendant cet événement annuel
il ya des milliers de ballons qui sont
réunis et qu'ils volent toute la journée
mais ça doit vraiment être une
expérience incroyable quand même le
train à bord duquel circulent ben a une
autre particularité il relie le canton
de vaud où l'on parle français et le
canton de berne où l'on parle
majoritairement allemands l'arrêt
convient de passer là c'est rouge dont
je me souviens j'avais fait un camp
d'école et c est le prochain arrêt c'est
c'est sarens et déjà d'un canton de
berne donc ici au parc français et après
on traverse la fameuse arrière le rush
qui comme on appelle ça pourrait arriver
dans le canton de berne et puis la
banque parle que le suisse allemand donc
en fait on quelques mètres en quelques
centaines de mètres on passe du français
à l'allemand c'est comme ça en suisse il
ya des villages qui sont bilingues mais
la vraie ya vraiment une frontière de la
langue entre deux villages c'est assez
fou tout à fait donc c'est une frontière
de la langue mais en a comme tous un
petit peu la mentalité parce qu'on est
tous les montagnards
la suisse est un pays multilingue il y a
quatre langues officielles au centre du
pays on parle majoritairement allemands
à l'ouest les français et au sud
l'italien une minorité de suisse 0 5% de
la population pour être précis parle
également leurs manches cette diversité
de langues s'explique par la position de
la suisse qui partage ses frontières
avec l'allemagne la france le
liechtenstein l'autriche et l'italie
je vous propose maintenant de retrouver
ben à bord d'un autre train mythique qui
empruntent le même chemin de fer le
golden pass belle époque
niklas est ce que tu pourrais nous
parler un petit peu de ce train
emblématique cet art
un unique parce qu'il est de style belle
époque des années 1930 il y en a pas
d'autres en suisse de ce style il roule
tous les jours dans un horaire régulier
augmenterait raymond bo montrevault
lemberg nous avons des voitures
similaires depuis les années 1914 15
déjà donc c'était même une collaboration
avec la compagnie internationale des
wagons-lits à paris donc ce train part
de montreux il va jusqu'où de montreux
il grimpe sur les avants chatons des
stands et il se termine assez siemens
dans la vallée de la cie mais là bas les
gens ils continuer pichanges train pour
aller en élection d'interlaken et de
berne
arrêtons nous quelques instants à berne
cette ville se distingue par son centre
historique classée au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
mais ce n'est pas tout berne est
également connu pour avoir hébergé un
certain albert einstein
on connaît tous albert einstein on a
tous entendu parler de lui moi
personnellement j'ignore complètement
ou est ce qu'il a vécu qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé dans sa vie à part le fait
qu'il ait trouvé la théorie de la
relativité
il est né à ou en 1879 en allemagne donc
mais ses parents tout de suite après
deux ans changé de domicile sont allés
vers munich
là il a fréquenté les écoles avec sa
soeur maya et quand il était au lycée
avec une autorité prussienne ça lui
déplaisait totalement il est parti à 15
ans sans diplôme
ils savaient très bien qui voudrait
étudier et ensuite de nouveau ses
parents sont partis vers l'italie et les
a suivis mais il trouvait non je cherche
un pays démocratique et c'était la
suisse il a vécu à berne donc il avec
eux à berne depuis 1902 jusqu'à 1920
quand il avait terminé ses études
d'assurer qu'il trouvait pas d'emploi
alors il a travaillé comme instituteur
auxiliaires mais il savait très bien que
ça fonctionnait pas et pendant les
études il a fait connaissance 2000 et va
naturellement il a adoré parce qu'elle
était aussi intelligente que lui et les
deux se sont promis le premier qui a un
emploi on va s'épouser albert einstein
et millet vama reach ont été mariés
pendant une dizaine d'années de 1903 à
1914 période au cours de laquelle le
physicien a publié une grande partie de
ses travaux révolutionnaires mileva
elle-même physicienne n'a jamais
revendiqué sa participation aux grandes
découvertes de son mari mais après la
publication de certaines lettres la
communauté scientifique a commencé à
s'interroger
tenez en 1901 albert écrit amis leva
comme je serais heureux et fier quand
nous aurons tous les deux ensemble mener
notre travail sur le mouvement relatif à
une conclusion victorieuse à la lecture
de ces lignes on se demande quel a été
son implication réelle dans les
recherches de son mari bien sûr ça
n'enlève rien au génie d'albert einstein
l'enjeu du débat est plutôt de savoir à
quel point mileva l'a aidé et si elle
n'a pas été victime de l'effet mathilda
une théorie selon laquelle la
contribution des femmes scientifiques à
la science est souvent minimisé au
profit des hommes
il avait cueilli à ses proches des
cibles à shanghai ci était très modeste
il y avait quelque chose
une armoire en lit très dur mais ce
qu'il a fait il a écrit une lettre à me
lève à il a dit mon dieu nous avons un
canapé très confortable nous avons des
chaises vraiment rembourrés nous avons
trois armoires et je pense qu'il a voulu
convaincre est que me levano suite
jusqu'ici à berne
add on qui lui a menti mais je pense
qu'il était convaincu qu'il pouvait
vraiment faire venir mileva jusqu'ici à
berne a pour qu'elle voie où il dit mais
il faut savoir qu'à pas juste des
statuts de lui un peu partout en ville
ou encore son premier appartement à
berne
il ya aussi un musée einstein dans les
murs du musée d'histoire de berne et
c'est là qu'on va maintenant rencontrer
daniel guide et spécialiste du physicien
théoricien daniel on a vu ce matin la
maison d'einstein on a étudié un petit
peu sa vie de famille est ce que tu
pourrais nous éclairer sur ses
découvertes
il fait ses recherches de physique dans
ce temps titre et c'est incroyable parce
que il est un absolu inconnu dans la
matière que la c6 est il trouve dans une
année 1900 serreau 5,4 à théorie qui
était une révolution qui me gêne pas du
tout dans le milieu de la physique qui
l'a fait c'est utile il avait aussi tels
que connaît qu'ici à perdre avec qu'il
ne pouvait discuter ces théories mais il
n'est pas professeur dans une université
ils n'avaient pas de lien strict aux
autres universités cette trempe il a
fait ça plus ou moins seul e et il ya
les c2 c'est souvent à cette équation
que l'on résume les travaux d'albert
einstein
en réalité il en a écrit beaucoup
d'autres sont entrés dans les détails
tous les scientifiques 50 sur le fait
que sa théorie de la relativité générale
a révolutionné la physique moderne et
les travaux d'einstein ont ainsi permis
de mieux comprendre le fonctionnement de
notre univers rien que ça direction
maintenant la région des trois lacs à
l'ouest du pays
comme son nom l'indiqué elle regroupe
trois lacs le lac de morat le lac de
bienne est le plus imposant le lac de
neuchâtel où je vous propose de
retrouver d'être
[Musique]
salut jamie aujourd'hui tu m'as envoyé
au laténium à neuchâtel en suisse pour
aller visiter un musée d'archéologie
c'est magnifique
bonjour enchanté géraldine ou est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui on se trouve au
laténium sur la commune d'auterive juste
à côté de neuchâtel et on est au bord du
lac de neuchâtel
petit tour dans le musée jamie
tu as vu jamie tous ces outils ont été
retrouvées tel quel les regarde jamais
ils ont même retrouvé du pain
effectivement ça n'a pas vraiment dû pas
comme ça mais c'est bien du pain et là
on a même une assiette avec des restes
de nourriture au fond c'est fou en 1868
1878 et a eu ce qu'on appelle la
première correction des eaux du jura qui
a créé un abaissement artificielle du
niveau des 3 lacs et notamment de celui
direct de neige atteint il y à 150 ont
toute la région étaient marécageuse est
régulièrement inondée par la rivière
l'art l'eau envahissait les maisons et
détruisez les cultures à la fin du 19e
siècle
les autorités décident de réaménager
complètement la small quatre canaux
principaux et une série de petits canaux
sont construits ainsi que des barrages
l'objectif contrôler les au dollar et
relier les trois lacs pour en faire des
réservoirs de régulation cet immense
aménagement est plus connu sous le nom
de première correction des eaux du jura
ces travaux ont permis d'abaisser le
niveau des lacs d'environ 2 mètres 70 et
d'assécher la zone les archéologues ont
alors pu avoir accès à des sites
préhistoriques
les fouilles ont mis au jour des
milliers d'objets et des vestiges de
maisons sur pilotis dans lesquelles
vivaient les habitants de la région
il y a trois mille ans tout ça a été
submergé
ça a été conservé dans l'eau et au
moment de la correction des eaux du jura
bas avec l'abaissement de l'eau au puits
de légende
et se servir parce que vous avez des
ruines ici * dans le musée on a surtout
des petits aux grèves mais tu verras
dans le parc on a des mots constitution
un peu plus monumentale de choses qui
ont été retrouvées enfouies et ça te
rappelleras peau tatouée
ok donc là on arrive devant une
reconstitution
exactement c'est une reconstitution de
maisons lacustres tels qu'on les
construisait à la fin de l'âge du bronze
c'est à dire il ya 3000 ans tu es une
reconstitution fidèle à partir
d'observations côté faites sur des sites
archéologiques sur les rives des lacs
les maisons sur pilotis repose sur de
longs pieux en bois profondément ancrées
dans le sol ce qui permet de se protéger
des innovations de l'humidité et les
moustiques
il ya un bassin la bassée pour délimiter
justement le niveau way exactement
bassin qu'on peut voir à berlin de se
rendre compte de la hauteur de l'eau
avant la première connexion des eaux du
jura
le lac est ici et tu vois le mieux là
bas l'eau du lac arriver jusqu'au niveau
du mur ça fait à peu près de 2 mètres 70
donc théoriquement là je suis sous le
niveau de l'eau à bientôt
oui à trèbes à neuchâtel après la
première correction des eaux du jura
la région a connu une nouvelle
inondation dévastatrice en 1910 il a
donc fallu renforcer les aménagements en
place un nouveau barrage a été construit
et les canaux ont été élargies derniers
aménagements date la modernisation de la
centrale hydroélectrique de hagneck sur
les rives du lac de bienne
construite en 1900 elle a été totalement
modernisé et inaugurée en 2015 ben tu
nous fait visiter
[Musique]
ma
là je suis actuellement tout temps de la
centrale je sais pas si tu vois très
bien mais il ya des tourbillons c'est la
clau passe dans les turbines est en fait
les turbines sont vingt mètres de soul à
l'eau passe au travers des turbines créé
les sociétés ressort de l'autre côté
quand les poissons se retrouvent ici il
faut pas qu'il se retrouve coincé en
dessous il ya des passages pour qu'ils
puissent se retrouver de l'autre côté
[Musique]
les gros tuyaux bloc n'a pu voir c'est
par la clau passe écrit d'exister au
travers des turbines et ses deux grosses
turbines permettent de créer de
l'électricité pour à peu près 25 mille
foyers impressionnant
revenons maintenant sur les bords du lac
de neuchâtel suite à la correction des
eaux du jura
les oiseaux se sont approprié les
nouveaux marc est apparu sur la rive sud
est du lac ce site s'appelle la grande
cariçaie et il regroupe huit réserves
naturelles sur près de 3000 hectares
ans
jamie je suis actuellement avec le
directeur de l'association birdlife
swiss françois bonjour bonjour on sait
que la grande cariçaie est une énorme
réserve naturelle
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial
c'est plus exactement un chapelet de
réserve naturelle qui est aux fêtes
organisées sur les 40 kilomètres de
cette rive du lac de neuchâtel c'est un
haut lieu pour la diversité biologique
en rencontres sur cette rive sud
un quart des espèces animales et un
tiers des espèces végétales dont des
plantes qu'on peut rencontrer en suisse
donc c'est vraiment une roue lieu
incroyable et qui est préservée
maintenant depuis quelques dizaines
d'années qui est protégé strictement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
petit peu de cette association on a à
peu près 70 mille membres
et puis on travaille beaucoup dans le
domaine de la biodiversité on utilise
souvent les oiseaux comme emblème de la
biodiversité
on s'engage dans des programmes concrets
de conservation de la nature et des
espèces
on essaie aussi d'influencer les
politiques pour qu'elles soient plus
attentifs à la préservation de la nature
[Musique]
c'est magnifique c'est beau hein tu vois
on est sur un ponton comme ça qui
traverse la zone naturelle ce qui fait
que d'une part la végétation est pas
piétiner on voit que la zone est bien
protégée autour qui en même temps pour
la faune les animaux savent qu'on reste
sur ce chemin et londres aussi qu'on
s'écarte pas ce qui fait qu'on arrive à
une cohabitation à ses proches entre la
faute et loeb est le signe de la grande
cariçaie accueille pas moins de 390
espèces d'oiseaux comme le grèbe huppé
la panure à moustache ou encore la loti
stèle du cygne aux ide en janvier 2021
et les ornithologues ont recensé près de
88 1000 oiseaux sur le site
certains y vivent toute l'année d'autres
les oiseaux migrateurs ne font que
passer
c'est le cas par exemple d'une espèce de
canard le fuligule morillon à l'arrivée
de l'hiver il quitte la sibérie s'envole
pour la suisse où il hiverne dans la
grande cariçaie mais pourquoi cette
réserve attire-t-elle autant d'oiseaux
et bien parce qu'ils y trouvent un
refuge protéger et riches en nourriture
au menu insectes poissons mollusques et
autres amphibiens la grande cariçaie
leur offre pour ainsi dire le gîte et le
couvert et donc dans la réserve tout est
naturel
ben non c'est un paysage en fait qui est
largement influencée par l'homme parce
que c'est un milieu qui a une dynamique
naturelle assez forte et en particulier
la forêt a tendance à coloniser toutes
ses surfaces de marais donc on
intervient beaucoup pour maintenir ses
valeurs naturelles ici l'homme en
fauchant par exemple c'est ce que tu
peux voir sur les parcelles qui se
trouve
ici par exemple aussi en protégeant la
rive contre l'érosion avec des
palissades de pieux comme ça on arrive à
maintenir cette biodiversité assez
extraordinaire qui est dans cette
réserve
on a souvent tendance à penser que
l'homme n'intervient pas dans les
réserves naturelles et pourtant la
nature a parfois besoin d'un petit coup
de pouce pour trouver son équilibre
c'est le cas de la grande cariçaie
menacées par l'érosion de ses rives
à cause de l'eau et du vent les rives
recule en moyenne d'un mètre par an pour
lutter contre cette érosion
il est possible d'implanter des
palissades en bois parallèle à la rive
les pieux sont enfoncés profondément au
fond du lac est maintenue au moyen de
pierre c'est pas nissan protège la rive
des vagues elles retiennent également
les sables l'objectif est de favoriser
l'implantation des roseaux afin qu'ils
puissent prendre à terme le relais des
palissades de manière naturelle
ça jamais
wahaha
cette plage est incroyable je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait ça ici c'est fou et je
peux comprendre le succès qu'elle a sa
particularité c'est qu'il est vraiment
comprises complètement la réserve
naturelle c'est un peu un pari à
l'origine de ces réserves c'est de faire
cohabiter loisirs tourisme et puis
protection la nature et donc il ya des
zones assez ouverte au public comme ici
puis d'autres qui sont plus protégés
alors la difficulté à partir de là c'est
que sur une plage comme ça on peut avoir
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
et puis à partir de là des gens qui
respectent pas forcément les
réglementations et puis qui partent de
part et d'autre dans la réserve
naturelle et paddle entre autres un
voile après le paddle ben c'est
actuellement une activité que s'est
beaucoup développée depuis trois quatre
ans maintenant
et puis ces rixes une activité super
assez bon marché malheureusement les
gens sont pas tellement informé des
réglementations tour et puis on a
souvent des gros dérangement sur les
oiseaux de partir de cette zone de plage
[Musique]
c'est vraiment magnifique
je regarde pas trop être dans son studio
la prochaine fois on inverse peine je
vais sur le terrain et je te laisse mon
atelier
en attendant je te propose de prendre un
peu de hauteur à 2000 mètres d'altitude
pour être tout à fait exact
direction le glacier de fait à saas-fee
dans les alpes valaisannes
je pense que ça va te plaire
[Musique]
salut jamie je crois que tu as lu dans
mes pensées parce que tu m'as envoyé
dans mon élément naturel la montagne et
plus précisément aujourd'hui un glacier
c'est pour ça que maintenant j'ai rendez
vous avec un guide
ensuite on va les faire une petite rando
et peut-être descendre dans des
crevasses son histoire de voir un
glacier de plus près waouh c'est beau on
dirait une mer de glace
donc on va s'accorder et puis c'est
parti on arrive à la première crevasses
où c'est énorme
cette crevasse vers environ 60 mètres de
profondeur c'est difficile à évaluer
comme ça faut pas tomber un une chute de
60 mètres ça fait pas du bien restez pas
trop au bord il y avait toutes petites
crevasses mais ces petites crevasses
tout filmé façon profonde par contre on
voit pas le fond c'est assez font des
petites crevasses comme celle là il y en
a un peu partout on peut pas vraiment
tombé dedans on est tombé sur une
immense crevasses c'est presque un
canyon et c'est tellement énorme mike
qui est en train de préparer la corde et
après je vais descendre dans la crevasse
ne stresse pas du tout
[Musique]
discret et se fait alors on a compris
comment apparaissent les crevasses mais
les glaciers
comment se forme et il est bien ils
naissent par accumulation de plusieurs
couches de neige en montagne la neige
tombe puis se tasse au fur à mesure sous
le poids des nouvelles couches de neige
qui la recouvre à terme la neige fini
par se transformer en glace bien compact
en l'occurrence les scientifiques
estiment que les plus anciennes glace du
glacier de fait se sont formées il y a
deux cent à trois cent ans à la fin du
petit âge glaciaire
c'est assez fou tout ces bâches ont été
installés pour éviter que cette partie
fondent et je sais qu'ils font ça dans
plusieurs endroits sur des glaciers pour
éviter que le gars sait font trop vite
parce que c'est le gros gros gros
problème des glaciers sont tous en train
de fondre à cause du réchauffement
climatique les scientifiques observent
une accélération de la fonte des
glaciers en suisse ils estiment qu'ils
ont perdu près de 13 % de leur volume en
seulement dix ans jamie on vient de
redescendre du glacier et j'ai quelques
petits fun fact pour toi depuis que ça
ce fait a été créé ils ont que des
petites voiturettes électriques en
veille à nîmes qui arrive justement un
taxi un taxi électrique
toutes ces petites voitures c'est tout
les mêmes quasiment il ya des petits
shottle un peu partout et c'est
électrique elle il faut savoir que toute
l'énergie créée pour la ville et pour
les remontées mécaniques et de l'énergie
hydraulique non créés par les barrages
pour en revenir au glacier j'ai quelques
petites questions à poser un glaciologue
david on va le retrouver tout de suite
c'est parti et voilà ça y est j'ai
retrouvé david le glaciologue et je vais
lui poser quelques questions concernant
les glaciers
une des questions que je me pose c'est à
quoi sert agressé merci beaucoup et si
nous ne réduisons pas nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre tous les glaciers
suisses pourraient avoir disparu d'ici
2100 pour terminer notre tour de suisse
je vous propose de revenir à notre point
de départ dans le canton
[Musique]
jamais je me trouve actuellement dans le
parc naturel régional jura vaudois et
comme tu peux le voir je suis pas tout
seul mais pas mal de matches ici
la particularité de cette région c'est
ses murs de pierre on va les rencontrer
tout de suite eric et qui est mûr pied
pour qu'il nous explique un petit peu à
quoi servent ces murs quelle est la
technique qu'ils utilisent pour les
construire bonjour eric bonjour en plein
travail je vois en plein travail voilà
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle avait à peu
près 700 kilomètres de murs dans cette
région on estime à peu près 700 km mais
si on prend l'ensemble du jura des deux
côtés de la frontière français et
suisses étaient des milliers et des
milliers de kilomètres jamie eric va
nous montrer comment on construit ses
murs parce qu une technique très spécial
je construis deux murs qui s'appuiera
sur l'autre tu vois les pierres sont
toutes inclinées vers l'intérieur du mur
de manière à ce qu'elles puissent pas
s'échapper sur l'extérieur en fait les
forces s'annulent
elles sont appuyés d'une contre l'autre
elles peuvent pas sortir il faut
absolument que le mur soit le plus
compact et le plus rempli possible et
oui c'est vrai qu'on voit bien la forme
pyramidale
cette province est salée pour une
question de solidité puis ici on a des
pères qui sont vraiment très irrégulière
si on a des pierres vraiment
rectangulaire on peut se permettre de
faire un mur plus ou moins verticale
alors qu'ici c'est des pierres et
régulière donc en général je donne un
fruit de l'ordre de 15 à 25% en général
le mur est plus large à la base qu'un
camp auteurs et puis alors bas le
principe c'est de mettre des grosses
pierres à en base pour pour la stabilité
du mur toujours inclinées vers
l'intérieur
et puis après une fois qu'on a
avant qu'on fait ce mur qu'on arrive à
une hauteur donné environ 80 à 90 cm je
finis avec des grosses pierres qui qu'on
appelle découverte et qui relie ces deux
côtés et puis comme ça ça fait un espèce
de coffrage le mur est fermé et
normalement tout est coincé plus rien de
bouge d'accord il est taillé en fait
pour qu elle n 7 pour casser quand même
le moins possible le moins possible
parce que j'estime que d'abord su perdre
du temps tailler les pierres ça peut les
fragiliser en fait de l'étape est
d'accord alors c'est à moi de me
débrouiller pour trouver la pierre qui
correspond
autre ou existants que jamais maintenant
ça va être à mon tour eric va montrer
comment on pose les pierres ce sera à
moi de faire les murs de pierres sèches
sont un héritage du xviiie siècle par
avance les agriculteurs utilisaient le
bois pour séparer les propriétés et les
parcelles
mais ce système était peu durable en
moyenne les clôtures en bois
disparaissait au bout de 15 à 20 ans et
puis les ressources forestières
commençait à chuter dangereusement
progressivement ses clôtures en bois ont
donc été interdite au profit des murs de
pierres sèches et c'était plutôt une
bonne idée puisqu'ils sont toujours en
place
bon ça demande quand même un peu
d'entretien bon courage ben en fait
tomber toujours les plus grosses pierres
en bas du mur ont déjà les plus longues
parce que le mur est plus large devrait
plus de place et puis elles sont moins
lourde à porter alors tu vois celle ci
tu vois il ya un profil qui est sérieux
lirez dans l'autre sens voilà c'est pas
si mal construit un mur bon j'ai posé
une brique pas trop mal un parfait et
plus que quatre mètres de mur eric qui
m'a dit que le mur avait l'utilité de
retenir le bétail est ce qu il a aussi
une autre utilité ça fait un abri pour
un tas de petits animaux en partant des
escargots on trouve des grenouilles des
lézards bien sûr et puis aussi les
hermines qui aime bien courir dans ces
murs et puis justement à la recherche de
lézards ou de deux petites souris et
puis justement ici j'y trouve une pierre
avec un trophée alors le trou traverse
la pierre donc j'ai fait une petite
niche derrière grand comme la moitié
d'un ballon de football on va dire et
puis ça permettra peut-être à une
hermine
une souris de faire faire ses petites
maisons les murs de pierres sèches sont
un véritable écosystème qui abrite une
flore et une faune très diversifiée à la
surface les pierres accueille des
mousses et des lichens et même des
algues les cavités naturelles creusées
par l'homme comme on vient de le voir
avec ben servent quant à elle de refuge
à de nombreux animaux en particulier
pendant l'hiver pour se protéger du
froid
on y trouve des insectes et des tout
petits reste il comme les lézards ou
désormais mais aussi des mammifères
comme l'hermine et le campagnol votre
avantage
ces murs relie souvent plusieurs milieux
naturels entre eux les pâturages la
forêt les prairies ils constituent donc
des corridors pour les animaux qui
peuvent s'y déplacer en toute discrétion
à l'abri des regards
regarde jamais les spectatrices ça va
les gars qu elles ont l'air sympa tes
copines
j'espère que notre petit tour de suisse
vous aura plu en tout cas moi ça m'a
donné faim
le plus difficile c'est de choisir mais
je vais faire comme avec la suisse un
morceau de chaque
[Applaudissements]